au practice jeudi 1er septembre entre
les etats-unis et la france on retrouve
une nation golfique peu connu du grand
public le zimbabwe ces trois sportifs
ont fait 18 heures d'avion avec leur
coach pour venir jouer ces championnats
du monde amateurs par équipes organisée
dans les yvelines et caen c'est un
honneur parce que c'est quelque chose
que peu de personnes peuvent faire ou
auront la chance de faire
donc c'est un vrai honneur de participer
à ces championnats du marché relégué
derrière le football le rugby ou encore
le cricket le golf est loin d'être le
sport roi au zimbabwe le sport compte
seulement vingt mille golfeurs sur son
territoire mais cette nation veut faire
grandir ce sport et envoie régulièrement
des équipes sur ces championnats du
monde amateurs une bonne nouvelle pour
l'un des entraîneurs de l'équipe de
france on a parlé avec eux parce que
pendant la cérémonie d'ouverture on
était en étaient positionnés en dernier
et avec le z il était en avant dernier
et en a discuté on s'est présentés et
les championnats du monde c'est un peu
comme les jeux olympiques donc ça permet
à toutes les équipes de se rencontrer
dans la plus belle épreuve au monde et
je trouve que c'est formidable que tout
le monde puisse participer à ce genre
d'épreuve au niveau des résultats après
une première journée compliquée sur le
parcours du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ponctuée par
un + 15 au dessus du par l'équipe va
tenter de réaliser le meilleur score
possible à la fin des quatre jours de
compétition mais l'essentiel est
ailleurs
je pense que le plus important est de
participer de prendre de l'expérience et
apprendre des autres pays et des
meilleurs mais nous allons tous en même
temps c'est d'avoir
le zimbabwe nous a déjà assuré vouloir
revenir sur les prochains championnats
du monde amateurs pareil qui dans deux
ans et reprendront l'avion ce dimanche à
paris pour retourner au pays avec des
souvenirs plein la tête